oh man where to even start with this
um Candace Owens
has proudly and defiantly come out
against museums against museums we have
long spoken about the anti-intellectual
and pseudo-intellectual leanings of the
American right wing they used to sort of
couch them in a more uh what's the word
I don't want to say more defensible but
compared to now a slightly more
defensible way but now it is just
completely overt these are really
pathetic people and they are playing to
the lowest common denominator
a huge swath of the American right wing
doesn't read
doesn't think critically has no media
literacy skills and they just want their
beliefs spoon fed to them by Fox News
and people like Candace Owens and Ben
Shapiro and others and in order to keep
them in that state
right-wing influencers like Candace
Owens have started to make them feel
proud and confident in their beliefs
that books are bad learning is bad
museums are bad and here is a segment of
Candace Owens talking about how she's
actually very anti-museum take a look at
this next question what are your
thoughts on the British Museum and their
artifacts from other cultures yeah they
have returned many of them to Nigeria do
you think they should return them all
Jensen you know I actually kind of hate
a lot of museums because they seal our
tax dollars and so yeah defund all the
museums and send back all the artifacts
the amount of money that was given in
the covid bill the trillions of dollars
all of it going to like the Kennedy
Center the African-American Museum and
what do they do people that sit on the
boards take all the money it's kind of
become this huge money laundering
operation and yeah I say return it all
if you want to see something go to the
country you know so I'm actually totally
fine with that because only because I'm
very anti-museum because they stole a
lot of our money yeah interestingly she
pronounces museum museum which was but
the only two people I know that do that
are former producer Lewis and Candace
Owens we years ago we were wondering
where did Lewis get this Museum
pronunciation maybe he and Candace Owens
uh went to that same ritzy school in
Connecticut right no in all seriousness
uh this is the type of thing that many
right-wing and Republican voters
consider fresh and interesting and sort
of uh on the Vanguard of think uh the
modern Republicans love this stuff and
her idea is go to the country right I
mean if you want to see historical
artifacts like Egyptian mummies and
Roman statues and Greek pottery just go
to the countries it's just lying around
there you can just see it or if you want
to see
um you know artwork from famous artists
whether it's the Mona Lisa or you know
Van Gogh starry night or whatever go to
the countries whatever that means if you
want to see important documents like the
Magna Carta or the Gutenberg Bible or
whatever go to the country whatever the
hell that means this is part of a bigger
movement that includes Clips like this
this is Andrew taint
explaining why he is above reading books
he's above it he's too good or too smart
or too strong or whatever reading books
is a very cheap way to I guess entertain
I wouldn't call it entertainment because
my brain is far too advanced I'm too
smart to read right now you're sitting
there go smart people read no I need
action I need constant chaos in my life
to feel content I need to be driving a
Supercar and fighting a bunch of
hoes and champagne and going crazy I
can't just sit there oh why would you
read a book when you can have champagne
going crazy just exploding explosive
champagne all over the place you're not
gonna be bothered with a book and the
pirate on the boat
for people with slow brains right so
this is now now by the way do I do I
even really need to mention by the way
it actually
takes more brain power
and it's so fraught to use the term
intelligence it requires lots of brain
power
to actually go and get the information
out of a book rather than sitting there
with explosive champagne watching
reality TV now I have no problem with TV
or any of it right I watch TV I watch
shows Kaleidoscope on Netflix right now
by the way really good you know but the
idea of books are for the Lesser thinker
sort of thing is part of the same I'm
against museums or museums or whatever
pronunciation you choose and this is all
either with Candace Owens I believe it's
deliberate with Andrew Tain I think it's
not I think he's just kind of stumbling
across nonsense part of it is make the
people that follow you feel good about
just getting all of their beliefs from
you without thinking about them too much
without reading without learning without
looking at alternative sources they
benefit from people thinking books no
not for me
folks we are in a crisis on YouTube
something is happening on YouTube where
our Channel and others like ours appear
to be getting de-prioritized by some
kind of algorithm
I will have more information about this
when I have it
please remember like the video leave a
comment hit the Subscribe button it's
really the it's free and everybody can
do it and it will help us at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show